[MUSIC] The throne still held by the House of Lancaster to Mrs. Pretty,
once
unjustly usurped from the stalks like
you.  I have milk more noble than cherry blossoms Because the
right of succession to the throne surpasses language,
should I become a king?
Arouse a great storm in this land Got the golden heart, I'll definitely be back The golden heart is not in that heart,
but all the joys and happiness that the poets imagine I
want to fight with my father
[MUSIC]
Ah,
when I grow up, please support me on board
Richard,
the son who gave me my name I
'm counting on you Yes, my
father is my distance
Only my father can save me from the darkness
[MUSIC]
White  Wings of roses Eggs of red roses Beat the throne
by royals with crests of roses
6 Some
people call it a
war of roses
If
you get hurt any more, you'll be scolded by your mother
.
It's dangerous if you're alone.
I can do it with
you.
You can't go on the defensive alone
[music]
noco Shishi
Pa
du Minho
Purdue I'm getting
wet Shmari Puzzler oil that disobeyed God's
will How
about Yoichi?  A
large number of orphans were brought about by the
circumstances Fourth daughter history
of the stick Why
did you marry me?
A
white boar
might bite.
Harira helped me
out and I was just thinking of serving you at
dinner tonight.  What did you fall into
the mud?
When will I be able
to outrun the
Agnes and others
When I grow old, my arms will grow thick
When will I be
able to be like my father?
You've returned home
Finally, it's your father's round.
I swear that it will be a worthy loan
Underground I
certainly won the battle with the Lancaster The
Dagger
was badly damaged.
I had no choice but to stay as regent
I won't be king
until Henry, the era name,
dies  But
Father
[Music]
There's a paradise in there
All the
joys and happiness that poets imagine  Will once again cross swords with Lancaster
This storm will never stop until the golden crown shines brightly
Shine the dog and
prepare for battle
Great,
yes, I will help my father too.
No,
I'm still too young to devote my life to the soil
Planting the tape I'm going to leave my name as a training ground for my father
Ohno
no Reacher Please give up already We're still
children
Who are you?  Look at
the secrets you're hiding
Your body
[music]
Neither male nor female
Only my parents
know about this
.
] Come on
, the soldiers are exhausted from the long battle
.
[Music]
Celebrating Lancaster's victory I'm
Protecting my husband and my son
Mother and father more new
It's because that person, Omae, who became
Naru, tempted him by giving back to
his mother
.
[MUSIC] The
devil's child
God
, protect my husband and my son from the devil
[MUSIC]
2 Are you all right?
I'm making a terrible deal
[music] I
want to combine this
One minute and one minute, I'm thinking about how old it is and how many years it
will take to become a person's life
Strange guy
, all the shepherds
Are you a
shepherd?  It takes years
What a fun life It's
nice to have a carefree after-party
[Music]
That's right
, there are only tragedies and desires in this way That's
why a shepherd is happier than a king It
can't be
that cherry blossom  There's a dark edge in the house
I'm happier that I met you here now than if it's
a gunfighter Come on, come over here
[music] There's a
lot
Here, unlike heaven, you'll have terrifying
dreams  No,
you don't have scary dreams A
scary child,
Kita
I often have dreams of being abandoned by my mother
But in the end,
God will surely
reach out to me with a hand of light
Machine
Why should I live here?
[Music]
10th place
Light is
not
God  If you were sleeping around that time, the
god of death would come to pick you up.
That might be a good
idea, too. Death can save someone.
What effect will one shepherd die on the world?
I love you
I'm just a shepherd In the
end I'll be called to God's side like everyone else
No
[music]
Noro, good for you Can you
tell me your name
Richard
My name is Henry
Riccha
Do you want to be my friend
And
I'll stay here forever Yeah I won't whisper
two people  So if you hug each
other, well, you'll go back to another prison
Richard, who looks like Hawaii There's
no one to love you, but no
matter what prison, there's your
father, who will surely give you the light
It's my job to protect my mother until then
Music]
Henry,
there's Tosu's weirdness in his mouth. I
've been waiting for you.
But with just one front leg,
don't curl up your tail and get on the base easily
Dirty devil,
you have a secret in your body That
's what your mother must have told you
I heard from old plate The
devil's tail  But is it growing or is
the body of the kimono hidden in this?
I
wonder if this guy was a woman
What are you doing there when you get scared
Buddha
d Chard
Edward 23 new Don't worry about your mother
2  London, which we rescued just now, has
already been occupied by our own forces, and Henry has been captured. It's
our victory.
You don't have to dye it with your
adoptive father exchange ah ah
edward you did a good job for
my father i'm so proud of you at
all
You were splendid I hope there are people who are more suitable as heirs
I'm not the best
It's only natural that your life has started
No,
as long as Henry, who's not a king yet, is alive, it's starting
now  Henry should be executed immediately
Hold on d Chad's dislike is still worth using We
should proceed cautiously until Congress recognizes the high throne Well,
why don't you enjoy this banquet first
My daughters are princes
I'm nervous because
I want to dance with them at that time.
I want to polish myself I also
like that one Really
you're a strange woman You're also very strange
You're somehow
different from other people
4th place
You're alone Yes
, if you go to the battlefield,
Edward might not be able to win
Richard's heartbeat I
heard your voice on the battlefield
I was
in front of a special connection back then  I felt it,
Richard, my
father swears I'll never pull him back on the
battlefield, and
I'm close too.
I'll definitely show Henry's head.
[music]
me no
good me
me me
ni
[music]
me
[music
] night
me
nan wow
[music]
me
this is gee
denims
[music]
[applause]